helping our community with mental health
there's a new resource available that is
geared towards our Latino population is
holding a free 12-week program at the
CCSD Family Support Center and that's
where we find our Candace Charles this
morning with the impact that this
program is hoping to have and is already
making Candace
well for the last few weeks dozens of
families have filed into this building
here on Maryland okey to go ahead and
enjoy the family forward program which
really benefits not only the child but
the caregiver and the family as well now
we've told you the recent Studies have
shown that minority groups often have a
harder time finding Mental Health
Resources well that's where Fuente de
vita is stepping in to help fill the
gaps for spending on Latino families the
free program just got started and covers
a variety of topics parents can discuss
with their children throughout the week
including bullying and gun violence an
important topic as we continue to hear
about the unfortunate events unfolding
on campuses throughout the country the
program is intended to be a preventive
measure giving real meaning to it takes
a village
we want the people
happy free social a social affectionate
and share the very very good values here
in in Las Vegas
please come check the program we have
professionals the topics are really good
and they are teaching us like the best
ways to connect with our uh with our
kids
and there are more than a dozen sessions
left folks so plenty of times to sign up
we'll have those details for you on our
website newsnow.com again those sessions
are held here on Monday from six to
eight now the program is a trial run so
I'm trying to see if they can continue
it they're helping get grants for it
we'll support keep you updated on that
and they are accepting donations so if
you'd like to help you can also go to
our website and find out those details
as well for now live from the CCSD
Family Support Center off of Maryland
OPM Candace Charles 8 News Now